oh wow where am I
Phoenix Arizona at night did you
seriously just kidnap me and drive me to
the middle of the desert for a Dark
Phoenix pun oh I did much more than that
matpat so much more hello Internet
welcome to film Theory the show that's
awash in the blood of metahumans
seriously at this point dead superheroes
aren't a film theory what dead kids are
- game theory but today I thought we'd
look at a little less literal of a
killing and more of a metaphorical one
let's talk x-men's Dark Phoenix a film
that came out to the worst reviews in
the franchise's history and has grossly
underperformed at the box office which
honestly is really sad to me without the
original x-men film superhero movies
just wouldn't be where they are today
the one-two combo of x-men and then Sam
Raimi spider-man proved that a comic
book heroes most powerful ability was
the power to sell tickets the new movies
have been really solid first class and
Days of Future past were amazing like I
said those two were amazing and with
Dark Phoenix being the last in the
series now that Disney's in charge it's
a bummer to see such a pivotal franchise
go out not with the bang but with a
whimper so today I wanted to look at
what went wrong with this new movie I
mean its opening weekend earned half of
even the worst movies of the x-men
franchise that is serious when you're
doing worse than x-men origins Wolverine
you know you done goofed and admittedly
there's a lot of blame to go around
sophie turner struggling to maintain an
American accent while saying the word
father Michael Fassbender being just as
confused as to why Magneto's in this
movie as the audience is the marketing
team deciding not to put the words x-men
at the front of the movie's title in
giant bold letters guys and X with a
circle is just not gonna cut it when it
comes to brand awareness I saw that and
thought it was telling me that this was
a movie about railroad crossings but
those are all just two minor points well
about that last one I actually think
that last one is a really big misstep
you don't know this is
an excellent movie unless you know what
Dark Phoenix is referencing still the
biggest blame of all goes to one villain
in particular forget mr. sinister
apocalypse and juggernaut the entity
that's now proven itself to be the
greatest enemy to the x-men is Captain
Marvel but to really understand why and
wide to a level that no one else is
covering let me first quickly recap both
movies to you then things will start to
make a little bit more sense
Captain Marvel set in the early 90s a
strong independent female named Carol
Danvers is in a space related accident
with an experimental aircraft that
results in her absorbing cosmic powers
the accident also gives her sudden onset
amnesia her mentor actively lies to her
about her past but she learns the truth
which in turn unleashes her true
potential and she turns on the man who
was once her teacher setting out on a
massive mission of revenge oh and there
happens to be a race of shape-shifting
aliens called the scrolls that are
caught in the crossfire Dark Phoenix
send the early 90s a strong independent
female named Jean Grey is in a space
related accident with an experimental
aircraft that results in her absorbing
cosmic powers though she doesn't
experience any memory loss it's
eventually revealed that her mentor has
been actively lying to her about her
past since she was a little girl she
learns the truth which unleashes her
true potential she turns on the man who
was once her teacher setting out on a
massive mission of self-discovery oh and
uh there's a race of shape-shifting
aliens called the d'bari caught in a
crossfire
Captain Marvel released into theaters
March 8th 2019 Dark Phoenix was supposed
to release November second of 2018 then
again on February 14th of this year
months and then mere weeks earlier than
Captain Marvel are you starting to
notice a problem here okay so admittedly
I may have oversimplified the plots of
these two movies just a wee little bit
but there is very clearly a bit of
overlap between the two films female
superheroes with space powers and
counter shape-shifting aliens and deal
with their lying mentor and here I
thought releasing biopics of famous
musical artists named after their most
iconic songs within a six-month span was
a bad idea but in all seriousness the
overlap was originally gonna be greater
much greater you see Dark Phoenix
currently ends with the battle on a
train but
was originally meant to end with a
battle in space just like the ending of
another movie Captain Marvel according
to leaked reports off of test screenings
for the film the third act of Dark
Phoenix culminated in a full-scale alien
invasion at the UN where Jean Grey has
to launch yourself into space to defeat
the alien armada for
in the end gene sacrifices herself to
destroy the fleet it's something that
appears to be confirmed by Simon Kinberg
writer director and producer of Dark
Phoenix quote my original ending didn't
have the entire ex family together the
way they are in the film now usually
these big huge action movies have the
climactic moment in the third act I
loved the way that civil war had its big
action set piece where everyone's facing
off more towards the end of the second
act rather than in the third so that
after that huge battle you're left with
Winter Soldier Captain America and Iron
Man it's this telescoped down view of
their raw emotions and I loved how
intimate that was that's what I was
going for with Dark Phoenix is ending
even though and then might have looked
like Captain Marvel for about two
minutes
end quote so basically gene sacrifices
herself and the team winds up divided
that's how I read into that quote but in
the process as he admits it looks like a
Captain Marvel space battle for two
minutes so what's the big deal here it's
only like two minutes of similarities
between the two movies right well if you
calculate the time that Captain Marvel
is actually in space doing battle
against an armada of invading alien
ships it winds up being you guessed it
almost exactly two minutes okay so we
have two movies with strong females
getting accidental cosmic superpowers
while also being lied to by their
mentors leading them to ultimately
encounter shape-shifting aliens and have
a climactic space battle against an
armada of ships for exactly two minutes
but come on those sorts of coincidences
happen everyday in Hollywood it's not
like the x-men and Captain Marvel are
dealing with the same aliens invading
Earth right ah what are the d'bari and
one or the scrolls and Kree they're not
the same rights rights they're the same
freaking aliens aren't they yep the
d'bari who end up as the alien race in
Dark Phoenix and who go unnamed for
practically the entire movie which had
already tipped you off that this has
changed during reshoots were originally
meant to be the Skrulls in fact in the
comics the d'bari basically get one
panel in the Dark Phoenix saga in which
they're being wiped out by Jean Grey and
that's it that's all the
characterization they ever get not much
to build an entire villain civilization
around for your new movie Fox for
further proof that these shapes you
were originally meant to be the scrolls
we turned to an interview with the actor
of Cyclops High Sheridan quote there's
this huge battle between the guards at
the UN and Jean Grey and old guards turn
out to be scrolls and then Jean and
Scott are Scott is fighting Scrolls in
the fountain end quote and for further
proof we turn to the head scroll I mean
sorry
head to Bari herself Jessica Chastain
who had this to say about her character
so it was always like everyday kind of
trying to figure out you know the
mystery of who is this character and
then understanding that also with the
reshoots you kind of go oh it's changing
again you know I mean it was like a
constant evolution
so how was Dark Phoenix expecting to get
away with using the scrolls when it's
clearly a Marvel property well in truth
the question should actually be asked
the other way
many fans had assumed that the scrolls
couldn't appear in the MCU because of
their connection to the Fantastic Four a
Marvel property whose film rights were
sold to Fox back in the days when Marvel
was bankrupt Marvel being bankrupt man
if at first you don't succeed sell sell
sell to Disney but seriously the scrolls
first appeared in Fantastic Four number
two and then again in Fantastic Four
number 18 that was their origin seems
like it should be a slam dunk for Dark
Phoenix to use the property except like
all things in life it's more complicated
than that according to a tweet from
guardians of the galaxy director James
Gunn the scrolls actually have shared
custody between Marvel and Fox quote
some specific scrolls are at Fox but the
scrolls as a whole or co-owned end quote
so apparently Marvel gets custody
Wednesdays and every other weekend but
in all seriousness how did these two
movies end up like this the Dark Phoenix
saga is at its core a very different
story from Captain Marvel in the x-men
Dark Phoenix is all about a team of
mutants being forced to stop one of
their own from turning evil Captain
Marvel meanwhile is the exact opposites
the story of a solo pilot in her cosmic
case of Stockholm Syndrome so what
happened well James McAvoy the actor who
plays Professor X may have summed up the
situation best controlling through the
same
the source material seems I mean
obviously the Dark Phoenix saga and
Captain Marvel aren't the same comic but
in a lot of ways they may as well be
before the x-men were canceled in 1970
yeah that's another surprise it was such
an unpopular comic one of his first
release that it was cancelled for half a
decade in the 70s anyway back then Jean
Grey often went by the moniker Marvel
Girl and Captain Marvel is just Marvel
Girl after a few promotions right no
obviously I'm just joking but the to do
still share a remarkable heritage when
gene was brought back for the Dark
Phoenix saga it was by comic writer
Chris Claremont Claremont took Jean Grey
who at the time was considered a
throwaway character and made her a star
I mean literally he made her a star but
Claremont's career as a comic writer and
Reviver of throwaway characters was far
from over fast forward a few years and
Claremont is working on a comic called
Miss Marvel may be tempted to believe
that this is an evolution of Marvel Girl
with a bit more maturity but actually MS
Marvel was an entirely different
character not Jean Grey but Carol
Danvers Carol would decades later take
on the mantle of her predecessor and
become Captain Marvel but only after
Claremont's lobbying for his female
spin-off to take over for the
traditionally male role both characters
revived and molded in huge ways like
Claremont and so in a lot of ways the
source material really was the same even
all that being considered though
obviously the impending acquisition of
Fox by Disney didn't help things along
Captain Marvel may not have killed Jean
Grey but the Maus certainly did first we
saw what they did with the scroll in
Captain Marvel much to everyone's
surprise they're the good guys in that
movie would be confusing for audiences
to see them acting good in one movie and
then suddenly turning heel in the next
that happens only a month later or worse
for Disney Dark Phoenix releasing before
Captain Marvel and now the MC use big
female hero flick gets railroaded as
audiences grapple with the inconsistent
scroll treatment and Dark Phoenix gets
there first the mouse sacrificed Jean
Grey for Carol Danvers this was honestly
crucial since Disney clearly has plans
for the scrolls moving forward they know
where Marvel's headed into the post
endgame phase of movie
and the scrolls are 99% certain to
factor into that Kevin Feige the
mastermind behind MCU has been very
upfront when speaking about a branching
division of Earth centric films and
space centric films and with that comes
the continuation of the story of the
scroll as they are heavily involved in
some of the most iconic Marvel stories
out there specifically Secret Invasion
or fan favorite characters are suddenly
replaced by doppelganger Scrolls that is
an impossible plotline to pass up but
two movies using the same characters
would have just caused both of those
movies and specifically that race of
characters to suffer and so just like a
divorce with joint custody the primary
caregivers the one who gets the say and
in this case we're all forced to bow to
the will of Disney especially a
struggling studio that's looking to get
a 71 billion dollar buyout Fox and
that's kind of sad as we're going
forward into a world where Disney is
gonna own all but the DC superheroes we
may want to pause at this moment and
think about what this really means sure
it means awesome things like Wolverine
and Hulk finally sharing the screen
together but it also means no more fox
taking chances and doing things
differently
no more baffling fantastic for movies as
they desperately try to hold on to the
IP giving us movies that we can laugh at
for decades to come
no more Universal giving comic book
movies to angley but with two or three
movies coming out each year into the
foreseeable future
Disney is gonna have to start to learn
that some things are just gonna have to
overlap or we may end up with a lot more
dark Phoenix's on our hands but hey
that's just a theory
you